hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of balling the Masters
today we're gonna look at how a young
man orphaned as a teenager turned his
love of aviation into a multi-billion
dollar empire this is a story of Howard
Hughes
the top three lessons that you can learn
from his success Howard row Bart Hughes
jr. was an American industrialist
aviator engineer film producer director
philanthropist and one of the wealthiest
people in the world when Hughes was a
teenager he lost both his parents and
was left with the family inheritance
from money his father made by selling
his inventions ever ambitious he was
quoted as saying I intend to be the
greatest golfer in the world the finest
producer in Hollywood the greatest pilot
in the world and the richest man in the
world
Hughes aggressively pursued business
interests in Hollywood films airlines
and hotels and casinos to expand his
empire he managed to turn his $1,000,000
inheritance into a two billion dollar
fortune equivalent to 6.6 billion in
today's dollars Howard Hughes was and
still would be considered one of the
richest men
by being aggressive with his growth
plans and by keeping his eye on the
prize Hughes was able to become one of
the richest men in the world to help you
aggressively grow your business here are
three action items that you can learn
from Howard Hughes action item number
one surround yourself with the best as
entrepreneurs we can't do everything
ourselves I need to recognize what we're
good at
and what we need to delegate to others
to help us with getting the right team
in place is one of the most important
tasks you'll ever do as a business owner
after inheriting his father's company as
a teenager he was recognized that he
didn't have the know-how to run the
business and look for someone who could
he hired 36 year old Noah Dietrich to
become his accountant and right-hand man
on a $10,000 a year salary for the next
three decades Dietrich eventually became
director vice president and CEO of
various branches of Hughes's Empire
according the Robert Mayhew a chief
adviser to Hughes Dietrich was
delivering Howard profits of 50 to 55
million dollars a year big bucks in
those days action item number two don't
give up on your goals whatever your
goals are for your business you need to
keep attacking them until you accomplish
them forget about what other people say
and that the odds might be stacked
against you take consistent action every
day until you reach your targets and
believe that you can do it the hugheses
h4 Hercules was the world's largest
flying boat the largest aircraft made
from wood and had the biggest wingspan
of any aircraft ever built it was
contracted by the US government to
transport troops across the Atlantic to
avoid German u-boats in the Second World
War
nicknamed the Spruce Goose it was three
times the size of the largest plane ever
previously built nobody thought Hughes
would ever get it off the ground
kept pushing towards his goal despite
the naysayers according to Hughes the
thing was a black sheep
nobody wanted to fool around with it or
become contaminated by it we're working
in a complete vacuum as to information
based upon prior performance and prior
design I defy anyone today to design an
airplane substantially more efficient
than this one for its purpose action
atom number three be hands on being an
active part of your business is crucial
to its success you need to know when the
higher people were you also need to know
what your job is and show people that
you're dedicated to doing it and inspire
them to do their job to the best of
their abilities with some of the best
people in the industry working form
Hughes could have chosen to distance
himself from goings ons as the various
enterprises but instead Hughes chose to
be hands-on involving himself in even
the smallest of details he would
personally test fly all the planes that
he helped design he would often even put
his own life at risk
to involve himself and improve his
product he was also for the most part
adored by his staff who appreciated his
hands-on approach and were inspired by
his dedication and enthusiasm
according to Hughes if I've made a
mistake in the design then I'm the one
who should pay for it I certainly would
not ask somebody else to fly plane if I
were afraid to do it myself
so remember surround yourself with the
best don't give up on your goals and be
hands-on to finish up this video I
wanted to share some of my favorite
quotes from Howard Hughes and his best
true story
Hughes's love of flying roofs began when
he attended a Yale Harvard Boat Race
with his father after his father lost a
bet the Harvard would win the
fourteen-year-old Hughes was promised
anything he wanted while his dad
proposed buying him his own boat
Hughes jr. asked to fly in the old
broken-down seaplane anchored in front
of their hotel with the plane's old age
in its corroded wires he was his
father's initial reaction was no but
used jr. proved so persistent that he
could not be denied he finally gave in
said Hughes this was the very first
contact I had with flying throughout his
career many more were forced to give in
to Hughes his desires thank you for
joining me for another edition of Molly
the Masters if you enjoyed the video
please give it a thumbs up I'd also love
to hear your thoughts and feedback if
you want to leave comment below the
video and stay tuned to the next episode